all I wanted to do was fix my email I
did not expect to have a minor
existential crisis about how much the
world is about to change
normally this is the sort of talk that
I'd have given on stage at some
conference about the future of the web
but um I'm in New Zealand right now and
I also have this vague suspicion that
those conferences might not be relevant
for too much longer I was lucky enough
to live through the mass adoption of the
internet for anyone younger than about
25 watching this you won't remember just
how fast and how incredible that
transformation was and I was on The
Cutting Edge of it I was living it I was
one of the people who understood what
was going on
useful new technologies generally follow
a sigmoid curve you have a slow takeoff
as the technology is invented and the
major pain points get sorted out and
then you have this incredible explosion
of growth as people find it useful and
the technology gets better and better
and better and better and loads of
competitors enter the market and people
find more and more and more and more and
more real world practical uses for it
and there's this massive race to make
newer better bigger things that people
keep making more stuff with and then you
reach the limit of what's possible with
that technology and the rate of progress
flattens out again basically there's a
reason very few people camp outside
Apple stores for the new iPhone anymore
I remember Napster from back in 1999 and
in hindsight I think Napster was the
first big sign of just how many
industries were going to be changed or
completely destroyed by the internet not
just the music industry but travel
agents video rental stores encyclopedias
shopping malls big box stores the Postal
Service journalism the entire media
industry Napster wasn't the first sign
but it was the first major one that
millions of non-technical people were
using by choice the first one to get big
mass media attention and legal problems
it was the first big popular disruption
the first warning shot the first Rumble
of Thunder off in the distance that said
the storm was approaching that
everything was about to change I don't
think many people realized that at the
time and even if they did they couldn't
have predicted the world that would
follow the world that I grew up in the
world that I've got really comfortable
with the world of the web of social
media of smartphones this video you're
watching now is a very early 2023 video
and a very English-speaking one this is
a record of a point in time and base and
I might be wrong about this I don't know
where technology is going to go from
here but I think that world my world the
one I grew up in is about to change
radically I think we're on a new sigmoid
curve and I have no idea how far along
that curve we are right now and I don't
know if I want to change with it
but I think I'll have to and all I was
trying to do was fix my email
this is a really specific problem but it
really annoyed me and I have to explain
it for the rest of this to make sense so
bear with me almost every email system
has the idea of folders you have one
copy of an email and once you're done
with it you file it in a folder like a
piece of paper in a filing cabinet
because that's a mid-20th century
physical analogy that the inventors went
with
but in 2004 Google launched gmail which
threw all that out in favor of labels
email is just in one big pile you search
to find stuff and you add labels to help
me sort it I hate labels because I like
the analogy of folders that's what I
started out with that's what I was
already using I didn't want to change
for no reason
but everything else about Gmail was so
much better than any of the Alternatives
at the time that I moved over to it a
couple years later and I decided fine I
will just treat labels like folders I'll
change my workflow as little as possible
each thread gets one label that's light
putting it into a folder which meant
that when I backed up my emails which I
do never trust having only one copy of
something particularly if that copies up
in the cloud but when I did that I could
use a regular old school desktop email
program like Microsoft Outlook to make
that backup you can use programs like
that with Gmail accounts they talk to
each other if they didn't stuff like the
default mail app on iPhones wouldn't
work and people would complain but those
old school programs don't understand
labels so Gmail just lies and says their
folders great that means my email
program can talk to Gmail and request a
copy of all those messages one folder at
a time and then I know it's backed up
every message they're even stored in
actual email folders like I wanted
it took 15 years for me to notice that
that wasn't working properly I was doing
a routine backup last month and I
noticed that a threat in that email
backup was missing several recent
messages and that made me suspicious the
kind of discomfort that you get when you
know something is wrong but you don't
know what it is yet so I looked a little
bit further and I realized loads of
messages were missing my backup more
than a hundred thousand of them over 15
years they were still there in gmail on
the web but they hadn't been lost it's
just they hadn't been backed up and
that's because it turns out in Gmail
labels only attached to individual
messages and not the full thread that is
invisible to most people it's barely
mentioned in the documentation and it's
a really subtle annoying distinction if
you send an email put a label on that
thread get a reply and then just hit
archive that reply doesn't get the label
and as you go back and forth and add to
that thread none of the other messages
there get a label unless you're
explicitly untag and re-tag the whole
thread which means more than a hundred
thousand unlabeled messages weren't in
my backup
is this a really specific nerdy problem
that only I'm annoyed about yes
absolutely I'm one of the very few
people in the world but it's going to
affect loads of people don't sort or
label their emails at all and most don't
back them up but I needed to fix this I
needed my backup to work and I did not
want to change my damn workflow but how
on Earth do I fix every email thread
over 15 years without painstakingly
clicking through all of them
I grew up fixing things with code so
obviously that's where my brain went
Google has a service called apps script
it means that anyone can write simple
code to easily change and automate
things in Gmail calendar docs YouTube
whatever it's a brilliant service I have
no idea how it ever got married and it
will inevitably one day be shut down
with very little warning because that's
just what Google does
but apps script meant that to fix this
problem I could just spend an hour or so
writing a bit of code and it's been a
while since I've done that
first thing I do when I'm coding
something simple like that is I write
out what it's meant to do in plain
English just the flow of logic so I can
then use that as a guide so I wrote that
down and I thought hang on it's never an
AI thing that's meant to do this now yes
this is a video partly about chat GPT
but I promise I'm not going to go into
the details there telling someone about
your fascinating AI conversation it's
like telling someone about your dreams
they don't care it just sounds like a
hallucinating nonsense but I've seen
posts from people being freaked out
about just how good chat GPT is and
intellectually yeah I looked at it and I
agreed with them it seemed surprisingly
good but it is just a text Transformer
all it does is guess what the next word
in the phrase is and you had been seeing
some improvements in that lately I made
a video two years ago about the
sentences computers can't understand but
humans can and at the end of that video
I made a joke about how computers with
language skills are 10 years away just
as they have been for the last 40 years
uh I was wrong turns out that's pretty
much sold now but chat GPT is still just
a thing that predicts what the next word
is going to be it produces generic milk
toast output that's confidently wrong
about a lot of things it's going to help
spammers and maybe have a little bit of
real world use right but I thought okay
let's put my tax description in tell it
to translate this into this obscure
Google app script see what it does and
it wrote the code for me in a few
seconds and I felt this pit of the
stomach existential horror and at that
moment I couldn't explain why
but I figured it out later
it's just predicting the next word the
code it gave back was a bit wrong but
frankly my first attempt would have been
a bit wrong so I asked it in plain
English to fix a couple of the errors
that had spotted and it did and that
version was nearly right not quite
though it used a really strange approach
I tried to work out why it had done that
and then I realized I could just ask and
it told me in English why it had done
that and it had made the same mistake I
did with my backup because turns out
Google's documentation is wrong Google
apps script itself treats labels as
attaching to threads not messages Google
wrote their own programming language
wrong so I told chat GPT about the error
and it fixed the script it bodged its
way around Google's bad documentation to
build the thing I was actually asking
for and after all the back and forths I
didn't actually save much time but it
was so much easier I never had to pour
through documentation to find the exact
specific magical incantation that I
needed
also my coding skills are years out of
date that's one of the reasons I don't
make computer science videos anymore the
last time I learned a new thing in code
was probably 2015. my old skills were
good enough I didn't want to change my
workflow I'm not sure if chat GPT is a
better code than I am but it felt about
equal it felt like watching while
someone wrote code with me occasionally
chime in and going um I think yeah I
think you might have made a mistake
there and sometimes I was the one who
made the mistake at one point I realized
I'd written the wrong thing in that
first text description chat GPT had just
been following my wrong instructions I
know it's just a text model that
predicts what word comes next
but it didn't feel like it so at first I
thought that pit of the stomach
existential dread feeling was because my
brain had gone that's a human or that's
an alien intelligence or because I was
starting to think well what if my brain
is just a Transformer system that's
trying to predict what the next word is
I'm sure I remember some old pop science
article about how your brain's a
prediction engine and surprise is just a
fancy word for being wrong about what
comes next
but then the next day I gave chat GPT a
more difficult problem one that required
not just translating English to code but
actually a little bit of a logical leap
and it just confidently completely
failed in multiple obvious ways and that
meant that I wasn't worried about it
coming to my job not yet anyway sure no
one's asked for that exact problem to be
solved before the one about the labels
and messages chat GPT wasn't just
copying and pasting from somewhere there
was arguably creativity involved but if
I'm honest a lot of the programming I
used to do was just copying and pasting
bits from somewhere at some point every
modern programmer searched on Google or
stack Overflow and adapted something
that someone else wrote it's basically
part of the job at this point I'm
deliberately avoiding the argument about
creativity AI art and copyright by the
way I don't know how I feel about it and
I don't know how the courts will resolve
it if I hired a human artist or musician
to create a painting or song in a more
famous artist's style that would be
weird but it would be legal as long as
they're not pretending to be the famous
Artist as long as the smaller artist is
not trading on their name that's fine
the style of most of my videos on this
channel is just a slightly faster
version of the TV shows I've watched
growing up that's what this intelligence
was trained on and this video is
basically in the style of every other
video assist on YouTube just like trying
to go to the beach a bit more often if
someone set up an AI to generate YouTube
videos or even YouTube educational
videos as a genre I think I'll be fine
with that I don't think I'd have a
problem with my work being a small part
of a massive pool of training data but
if someone started ripping off
specifically my name and my work yeah I
can see why artists are Furious about
that the British legal term for it is
passing off I've said before please
don't train models on what I make or
frankly on any one specific without
their consent but okay I wasn't worried
about being replaced and I wasn't
worried that I was actually talking to
some human equivalent alien artificial
intelligence so why did I still have
that feeling of dread
artificial intelligence text
Transformers and diffusion models
everything that we're currently seeing
seems to be on that sigmoid curve of
progress and I don't know what point on
that curve we've got to if we're already
most of the way up the curb then cool
programmers and artists have brand new
tools but they can't create something at
a human level with them it's not going
to take many jobs it's going to make
people's work more efficient the same
way that loads of inventions like
Photoshop have done before
if we're at the middle of that curve
then wow we are going to get some really
impressive new tools very soon that
still needs some humans to work them
maybe Siri and the Google Assistant are
going to become the things that they
will always promised to be
but that feeling of dread came from the
idea that chat GPT and the new AI art
systems might be to my world what
Napster was to the late 90s The Herald
the first big warning that this new
technology the thing that was going to
change everything
was starting to actually change
everything where huge numbers of people
not just the Nerds were actively using
it and it didn't matter that Napster got
sued out of existence because by then
there was Morpheus and groxter and
LimeWire and Kazar and then there was
Spotify the old business model that idea
that you bought a copy of Music had been
struck a mortal blow and no one noticed
it for a while if you hear Echoes of the
Napster case in the lawsuits against AI
art programs
so do I I was getting a haircut the
other week and unprompted the barber
started talking about chat GPT and how
it actually used it to write a formal
email that he couldn't be bothered to
put together himself he wasn't a
particularly technical person he wasn't
a nerd like me but he used it easily the
same way that someone who wanted to get
a load of music for free would figure
out Napster it's not about chat gbt not
specifically it's about what it
represents
because if we're still at the start of
the curve for AI if we're at the Napster
point
then everything is about to change just
as fast and just as strangely as it did
in the early 2000s perhaps beyond all
recognition and this time I'm on the
wrong end of it I'm like the music
executive back in 99 it feels to me like
something might have just gone very
wrong for the now comfortable world that
I grew up with
and that I've settled down in
that's where the dread came from the
worry that suddenly I don't know what
comes next no one does I've been
complaining for years that it feels like
nothing has really changed since
smartphones came along
and I think that maybe maybe
I should have been careful what I wished
for at some point I'll look back on this
video and with hindsight I will easily
be able to see where we were on the
curve we all will part of me hopes that
I am entirely wrong that in a few years
I'll still be working like this the
email thing is a metaphor of course it
won't be email folders for you it might
be something else something you're
attached to maybe something minor or
maybe the whole industry you work in but
right now that feeling that creeping
horror that dread it turns out that was
the worry that after years of being
fairly steady and comfortable
my world is about to change and despite
everything
I will still want my email to be in
folders
and now an AI generated nordvpn ad today
I want to talk about one of my favorite
tools for staying connected while
traveling or just browsing the internet
it's called nordvpn and it's been a game
changer for me with nordvpn I can access
content from anywhere in the world no
matter where I am whether I'm in a
country with strict internet censorship
or I want to access a website that
blocks people from a particular country
or just want to catch up on my favorite
shows from back home nordvpn has got me
covered
some other amazing features of nordvpn
include the ability to connect up to six
devices simultaneously and 24 7 customer
support whether I'm using the laptop
tablet or phone nordvpn makes it easy to
stay connected and secure so if you're
looking for a VPN that can help you
access content from around the world and
to keep you safe and secure online give
nordvpn a try trust me you won't regret
it
to get the best deal they're currently
offering go to nordvpn.com Tom Scott or
click the link in the description
I am going to be out of a job sooner